[Music]
on this thursday night ontario's
healthcare action plan the remedy
drawing mixed reviews we're horrified at
some of these plans and the issue that
still needs attention the struggle to
keep cool it is hot i have no idea how
they're even surviving the rising risk
of rising temperatures indoors
new pressure to lift the lid what
unsealing the trump search affidavit
could reveal
plus stitching symbols of ukraine's
resilience and resistance
the canadian connection to a viral meme
that evolved into a powerful brand
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser good
evening and thanks for joining us for
months doctors nurses and patients
across the country have been sounding
the alarm about the state of our health
care system they've been calling on the
federal and provincial governments to do
more to address the ongoing crisis today
the ontario government responded with a
plan to help the system recover ahead of
what's expected to be a winter surge but
as mike draulia explains in our top
story tonight many front line health
care workers say they're worried the
plan includes private solutions to
public problems
understaffed and overwhelmed ontario's
healthcare system has needed triage for
months and while the ontario government
has refused to call it a crisis
meaningful action was promised this plan
is already in motion to add health care
workers and free up hospital beds doug
ford's government says it will divert
patients from ers by allowing some
surgeries in private clinics waive the
exam and registration fees for
international and retired nurses and
move patients from hospitals to
long-term care facilities underwhelmed
would be sort of an understatement we're
horrified at some of these plans the
ontario health coalition is particularly
worried about moving seniors unwillingly
to long-term care facilities that may be
far from home ultimately no we are not
going to be forcing anybody out of a
home but the changes do allow us to
continue that conversation however
seniors can also be transferred to
temporary care homes until their
preferred location opens up if we need
to we'll ask the human rights
commissioner to get involved and make a
ruling you know because this is serious
one part of the plan that's drawn praise
is the financial support aimed at hiring
more international and retired nurses
when you think of new immigrants you
could well imagine fifteen hundred
dollars is pretty significant
so with that kind of economic support we
may well be able to get more
iens into the workforce or certainly
that's the hope 600 international nurses
have been hired so far this year in
ontario and another 400 are on the way
but it's far short of the 20 000 the
health coalition says are needed in
ontario hospitals right now the health
minister sidestep questions around what
health care professionals say is the
biggest recruiting hurdle bill 124 which
caps wage increases for nurses at one
percent it's rather cynical that despite
all the intense scrutiny the government
is clinging on to this policy it's kind
of chilling that the one thing the
government could do
that would improve the morale and spirit
of nurses across this province who are
leaving in droves their jobs
is to address bill 124. the minister did
say more changes are on the way but
those actually on the front lines know
this is a crisis that can't afford to
wait mike trolley global news toronto
much of western canada is getting
scorched by another heat wave while
stretches of extremely hot dry weather
are increasing across canada they're
happening more frequently in the north
and in the west
exposure to extreme heat can have major
impact on people with vulnerable
canadians at greater risk but as lauren
pollen reports it's not just outdoor
temperatures that are cause for concern
at splash parks
on beaches
along rivers and lakes western canadians
are doing what they can to cool off and
cope the weather has been hot hot and
dry we're very thankful that we're lucky
enough to have air conditioning
but otherwise just trying to stay as
close to the water as possible the heat
has taken hold in most of western canada
nearly all of alberta in the red under a
heat warning and parts of bc started the
day the same way with temperatures
forecast to peak as high as 35 in metro
vancouver 40 in the bc interior and
topping 30 in southern alberta it
certainly gets dangerous when we see
these heat waves lasting a number of
days calgary for example is on day 10
being under a heat warning
extreme heat can turn deadly something
made alarmingly clear during last
summer's heat dome heat related deaths
in canada are a growing concern as heat
waves become more common and more
intense
and the fear is here for the most
vulnerable it is hot
i have no idea how they're even
surviving in there
western canadian farmers are also
feeling the heat with livelihoods on the
line it adds a lot of stress to you this
year was looking encouraging but
there's such a deficit of moisture in
the soil
that we
we have nothing to rely on for any
dry spells but the threat from scorching
weather doesn't stop at your front door
the key message is that indoor
temperatures matter and they matter a
lot people don't die because it's too
hot outside they die because it's too
hot inside
and while more and more western
canadians turn to ac as their new norm
for those without that option cooling
stations offer a safe escape when the
mercury hits dangerous highs
there is a reprieve in the forecast for
parts of b.c but alberta is not so lucky
with heat warnings expected for at least
the next few days
lauren pulling global news calgary
pope francis says there is insufficient
evidence for the church to begin a full
investigation into sexual assault
allegations against quebec cardinal mark
wallett one of canada's highest ranking
catholic leaders earlier this week the
allegations were made public when a
class action lawsuit was filed in quebec
superior court a woman identified as f
accused wallet of several incidents of
sexual assault between 2008 and 2010.
last year after the woman alerted the
pope of her allegations she was told
that a preliminary investigation found
no evidence to support her claims
that investigation was carried out by a
senior jesuit who is a close associate
of wallet while it himself is close to
pope francis he was among the
front-runners to become pope back in
2013. these accusations were contained
in one of two class actions filed
tuesday in which more than 200 quebec
priests are accused of abuse
reaction continues to pour in following
a global news exclusive that revealed
medical assistance and dying was offered
to a canadian veteran looking for
treatment for post-traumatic stress now
calls are growing for an in-depth
investigation into the incident and more
veterans are standing the alarm over the
organization tasked with helping former
soldiers return after duty our mercedes
stephenson has been following this
reaction since breaking the news earlier
this week mercedes this this story has
really hit a nerve
it sure has pharah i have heard from
dozens and dozens of veterans who are
outraged by this
and some of them knew about this before
it was really starting to to pick up in
the veterans community because they were
so hurt and felt so betrayed that
somebody who was seeking help who was on
the upswing according to
many friends who are close to him who
i've spoken to in his mental health and
his physical health and then suddenly
this happens it speaks to the lack of
trust that a lot of veterans have in the
system they believe the government would
rather see them die than pay for them to
live that is not borne out by what we're
seeing in terms of the facts and we have
to keep in mind that in that particular
scenario it was a one offer to that
veteran which we're still investigating
but the fact that this is how it would
feel to them says a lot about how they
feel the government is treating them and
a lot about how they feel canadians feel
about them and that raises serious
questions about the system mercedes i
mean how well is the system working for
veterans right now
well veterans will tell you largely that
it's not working very well but there's
some numbers to back up that perception
the auditor general says that the
canadian government needs to have a
long-term strategy to resource veterans
affairs canada properly we know that
they're supposed to finish claims and
assess them within 16 weeks but that's
not actually happening on average it's
double that length of time 37 weeks
pharah to assess a claim that's almost
part of me it's just over nine months
and if you're somebody who's waiting for
that money because you're unable to work
due to an injury sustained in your
service to the canadian forces vets
organizations say it could be the
difference between making rent and not
making rent there's also the lack of
continuity in cases veterans are
assigned veteran caseworkers but they
say they continue to change there's no
continuity and in this particular
situation we were talking about it was
only the second time that that veterans
affairs service agent had engaged with
that vet so there's just really no sense
of continuity and of ensuring that they
are having that ongoing care and those
home visits so they certainly need more
people in the system according to both
veterans and the auditor general still
lots of questions on this one mercedes
stephenson in calgary thank you mercedes
is the federal government qualified to
protect our privacy while handling
national security threats well most
canadians don't think so that's
according to a poll done for the
government and obtained by global news
through a freedom of information request
as tom vernon explains with global
conflicts being fought more and more in
the online realm our information has
become a target
the conveniences of a modern world come
with a cost we're all essentially
connected at all times but that can also
make us targets not just individual
canadians but as part of canada's
national security as a whole to fight
back police and spy agencies use these
tools as well but the technology is
changing so rapidly a parliamentary
committee will review canada's
communications intercept policies what
limitations the rules might have on the
gathering end and potential risks to
privacy rights changing the rules might
have this review comes as the government
tests the water on canadians attitudes
about how the government handles
personal information a poll of one
thousand canadians commissioned by the
privy council office obtained by global
news through a freedom of information
request found only one-third of
respondents are confident the government
shares information responsibly in order
to respond to national security threats
when asked if they felt comfortable with
the government getting greater
information sharing powers even if it
affects their privacy rights fifty
percent of the respondents disagreed
while only three in ten would be okay
with it we have to be wary of the false
dichotomy of security versus privacy
privacy lawyer constantine carbalyotis
says this is an important conversation
and he's never seen any evidence of
privacy rights getting in the way of
national security privacy and the police
have been front and center in recent
weeks in june the rcmp admitted to using
spyware on 49 devices in up to 32 cases
between 2017 and this year this gave the
force a range of tools from reading text
messages to listening in on device
microphones and even activating cameras
they were only able to do this with
explicit authorization from a judge
although canada's privacy commissioner
was never informed of its use
carbalyotis says that leads to obvious
concerns if there is really no harm why
didn't you do a privacy impact
assessment why didn't you submit it to
the commissioner
these are the ways in which we make sure
that we balance the risks against the
needs
law enforcement and spy agencies say
there are risks in the world it will be
up to ottawa to determine what private
information those organizations need to
protect canadians
tom vernon global news
edmonton
one wolf has died and another is still
missing after at least a dozen escaped
from their enclosure at the greater
vancouver zoo on tuesday this is the
first update from the zoo located in
alder grove bc since it became public
that the wolves got out officials say
one wolf was found dead on the side of
the road and another only a year old is
still missing police are investigating a
possible human factor in the escape
after finding a hole cut in the fence
but this next story proves there is
still good in the world beachgoers in
toronto dropped everything and acted
fast to look for a missing child
lifeguards and people on toronto's
woodbine beach worked together last
weekend when an eight-year-old boy was
thought to be missing you can see they
formed a human chain into lake ontario
and started their search fortunately the
boy was not in the water he was lost on
land and was safely reunited with his
family
legal issues keep piling on former u.s
president trump coming up the push to
publicize the affidavit leading to the
search of his home plus watch out it's a
bull in a peruvian shop
while questions continue to swirl about
what was exactly in those highly
classified documents found at mar-a-lago
a u.s judge has signaled he's willing to
unseal parts of the affidavit supporting
the search warrant on former president
donald trump's florida home but how the
government knew what to look for and
where is still a closely guarded secret
one that might be might not be
revealed rather in the weeks to come our
jackson proska reports on the latest in
a long list of legal woes facing trump
in a compromise meant to protect
sensitive information a florida judge
ordered the u.s government to redact
portions of the affidavit used in the
search of donald trump's mar-a-lago home
all for possible release
lawyers for the justice department
revealed their investigation is still in
its early stages it would certainly give
insight and reveal what the doj is
investigating how they know what they
know where they've been looking in court
filings justice officials warned
releasing the affidavit would serve as a
road map to the government's ongoing
investigation
doj lawyers say they're deeply concerned
about the safety of witnesses whose
participation led to the recovery of 11
sets of classified documents from
trump's home tell us the predicate for
the warrant reveal the affidavit this is
too important to democracy
but the former president and his allies
have insisted the underlying reasons for
the search warrant should be public
trump's lawyers notably did not
intervene to support the unsealing
but trump faces legal jeopardy on
multiple fronts federal prosecutors have
issued a grand jury subpoena for all of
the white house documents turned over to
the january 6th committee they're
investigating the role of trump and his
allies in the attack on the capitol
in new york alan weiselberg the former
chief financial officer at the trump
organization pleaded guilty to
conspiring with the company on a 15-year
tax fraud he'll spend five months in
prison in exchange for testifying at an
upcoming trial into the business
practices of trump's namesake company
and this week in georgia trump lawyer
rudy giuliani testified before a grand
jury part of a criminal investigation
into election interference in the state
i'm not going to comment on the grand
jury investigation the latest moves by
the court in florida suggest prosecution
is not necessarily imminent over the
mishandling of classified documents
but it's clear trump's legal troubles
are far from over
jackson prosko global news washington
almost four years after he was found
bludgeoned to death in his prison cell
charges have now been laid in the
killing of notorious gangster james
whitey bulger three men including a
mafia hit man have been indicted on
conspiracy to commit first degree murder
two of the accused were already behind
bars bulger was one of america's most
infamous mob bosses he was number two on
the fbi's most wanted list behind osama
bin laden before his arrest in 2011.
unprecedented sentence ahead why this
woman is being imprisoned for her social
media posts
[Music]
a bombing at a mosque in the afghan
capital of kabul has left at least 21
people dead and wounded more than 30
others heightened security can be seen
around the mosque one day after the
deadly blast ripped through the facility
during evening prayers no group has
claimed responsibility for the attack
but the islamic state has said it's
responsible for similar attacks carried
out in recent months there are fears the
death toll could rise as several of the
injured including children are still in
the hospital
a saudi court has sentenced a women's
rights advocate to 34 years in prison
for posting critical tweets and the
ruling is drawing outrage around the
world salma al-shahab was detained
during a family vacation last year just
days after she planned to return to the
united kingdom before the trip she
tweeted or retweeted several messages
calling for reforms in saudi arabia and
the release of activists a terrorism
tribunal convicted al-shahab of helping
dissidents and publishing false rumors
the unusually harsh sentence comes amid
crown prince mohammed bin salman's
crackdown on critics
three days of heavy rain has caused
major damage to roads and homes on new
zealand's south island
an atmospheric river has brought more
than 300 millimeters of rain in just the
past 24 hours several rivers have burst
their banks submerging roads and homes
and dozens of midslides have also come
down
so far more than 300 homes have been
evacuated and a severe weather warning
is still in place as another significant
rainfall is in the forecast
and at least six people are dead and at
least 20 people were hurt after a
powerful storm battered the french
mediterranean island of corsica heavy
rain and wind gusts topping 220
kilometers per hour swept across the
island uprooting trees and damaging
homes across the popular tourist
destination as many as 40 000 homes and
businesses are without power and more
rain is expected over the next 24 hours
a chaotic scene was caught on camera in
the peruvian capital of lima after a
bull slated for the slaughterhouse got
loose and caused a panic
the frightened animal sent people
running after escaping from the truck it
was being transported in the bull tore
through shops and reportedly injured at
least one person it was eventually
caught by locals in the area some 40
minutes after its capture
the meme that gained huge momentum next
the canadian behind a powerful new brand
in ukraine
it started as a meme a symbol that pairs
a traditional orthodox religious icon
with a high-tech tank-killing missile
now a canadian with ukrainian roots has
turned saint javelin into a brand and
high-profile figures including ukraine's
president have been spotted wearing the
armed figure as europe bureau chief
crystal gomensing reports saint javelin
is now hard at work raising both morale
and money for the ukrainian cause
a meme turned lifeline
somebody's there at the front for us and
we are here for them victoria redenko
and all the seamstresses working on the
saint javelin line
know their products help fund the
ukrainian armed forces to say it is a
labor of love
doesn't begin to scratch the surface
i have a son-in-law he's near donetsk
sometimes the illusion is created
everything is fine
and the work distract us because if we
were left with ourselves it would be
much harder
bassline is one of several ukrainian
businesses contracted to produce items
under the saint javelin brand
a former journalist in toronto with
ukrainian roots christian boris started
it with a borrowed image of the madonna
from a few stickers to a canadian
storefront st javelin has brought in
roughly 1.2 million dollars
in ukraine st javelin is now an icon of
the war a symbol of ukrainian resistance
one of the aim was to find
manufacturers that are in
areas
that need help that were
affected by the war if you can help your
help
this printing facility in nepro has
turned out about 1700 t-shirts
a big change from the days of filling
molotov cocktails on the production
floor
one of the project managers
is also a soldier
i think this is very cool and once again
i am convinced that the entire civilized
world has rallied around ukraine
a morale booster with a canadian
connection
being shipped around the world
crystal gavinson global news
keith
and that's it for global national for
this thursday night i'm farah nasser and
on behalf of our whole crew i want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's york
canada is this herd of dairy cows in
bybank saskatchewan we love seeing your
canada so please keep emailing us your
pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
you